[Music]
if you caught my direct message last
week you heard me explain why we
shouldn't let politics make us crazy yet
the crazy seems to be ramping up
everywhere you look these days
this constant onslaught of political
bickering has an incredibly polarizing
effect on most people
the fighting either makes them
obsessively tuned into politics non-stop
or reflexively tune out of politics
altogether with so much news and
commentary content out there if you give
me an hour or two of your week to hear
about political science philosophy
religion or anything else we're
discussing here I consider the time you
spend with me to be a pretty high honor
those of you who follow me on social
media outside of YouTube probably saw
that I spent last week on a farm with
family and friends outside of Seattle
though I spend most of the week hanging
out with 20 chickens and one duck who
thinks she's a chicken I had a couple
personal experiences with actual
real-life human beings which reminded me
why these aren't just abstract ideas
that we talked about here one of the
people on the farm with us was a trans
woman in her 20s who happened to grow up
on a pot farm she was also an avid
hunter and a guns rights enthusiast who
was painting her gun rocker bright blue
and pink at the time of our visit yes
trans women are sometimes into guns but
if you judge people as a collective
instead of as an individual this is
exactly the type of person who will
always go ignored I also spend some time
with a farmer who lived almost a hundred
percent off his own land but he was very
concerned with treating other people
fairly and making sure that others had
the same opportunity to succeed which he
had while his day to day life had a very
libertarian bent it because he provided
for himself and was living off the land
there was no doubt that he wanted there
to be assistance for people so that they
could one day share in the same
opportunity and pride in work that he
himself had attained his live and let
live attitude was blended with his
desire to do good for others in his
community he was a far cry from what
some would say about those selfish
libertarians or what others might say
about those authoritarian left
while I was away I also had a truly
awe-inspiring hike up Mount Rainier
which is part of the US National Park
Service this park is an incredible
example of a natural wonder that we have
right here in this country which happens
to be funded and protected by the
federal government you guys all know
that I'm a small government guy and I'd
always prefer local and state funding
but a place like Mount Rainier which is
so gorgeous and so powerful I believe
should have some federal funding and I'd
say the same by the way for a place like
Yellowstone National Park or Yosemite
the question here is how much funding or
the best way to pay for this funding
that's really what the debate is about
by the way Mount Rainier is also funded
by state and local organizations and I
met many great people along the trail
who are volunteering their time and
energy to a place they love so much that
right there is called putting your
beliefs into action not just demanding
that the government pay for something
with other people's money which is often
what we talk about my point here is that
people are complex issues are complex
and finding answers which will satisfy
everyone almost always is absolutely
impossible at the same time not only do
we all have our own strengths and
passions but we all also have our own
inconsistencies and blind spots
our goal shouldn't be about purity tests
so that people fall in line or adhere to
some false notion of perfection our goal
should be the acknowledgement of
differences so we stand up for the
freedom and for the Liberty that this
country was founded upon
[Music]
you